bienvenue à tous 45 minutes d'actualité
politique et parlementaire c'est
parlement hebdo à mes côtés aude
moracchini bonjour jean michael et
bonjour à tous et dans l'actualité cette
semaine est les aveux d'un homme jérôme
cahuzac avait bien un compte en suisse
ses aveux devant les juges en effet
d'une bombe politique
devant le scandale le président de la
république prend la parole l'opposition
met en doute la sincérité du couple au
lond héros et demandent la démission du
gouvernement
le texte sur le mariage pour les
personnes du même sexe c'est son nom
arrive au sénat
l'atmosphère est plus calme que lors de
son examen à l'assemblée nationale est
pourtant plus de suspense le vote du
texte se jouera à quelques voix
les manifestants étaient en nombre
devant le sénat et puis certains diront
que c'est un nouveau couac en tout cas
une confusion autour de la fameuse taxe
à 75 % françois hollande l'avait annoncé
la semaine dernière elle s'appliquera
aux entreprises et non plus au
contribuable reste à savoir quelles
seront des entreprises touchées les
clubs de foot par exemple sont dans le
collimateur ils ne veulent pas en
entendre parler et notre invité cette
semaine gérard longuet sénateur ump de
la meuse et depuis peu l'un des nombreux
vice président de l'ump bonjour merci
d'attraction en cette fin de semaine
vous êtes jetés au sénat dans la
bataille du mariage pour tous s'est
défendu ce vendredi matin une motion
référendaire on va bien sûr en reparler
dans cette émission
et bien sûr on va commencer avec les
suites de la sphère kayak avec nous
jérôme sainte-marie pour nous éclairer
vous êtes le directeur adjoint de
l'institut de sondage
c'est ça et on commence donc avec ce que
nous avons appelé l'ondé de choc
il avait nié droit dans les yeux et même
au coeur de l'hémicycle jérôme cahuzac a
finalement avoué mardi en fin de journée
devant les juges il a bien détenu un
compte en suisse
on attendait mercredi des questions au
gouvernement très houleuse on ne s'est
pas trompé compte rendu de séance avec
elisa berthelot mes premières questions
au gouvernement après l'éclatement de la
sphère cahuzac et c'est un ancien
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
demande des comptes au premier ministre
au delà du mensonge d'un homme la
responsabilité constitutionnelle et je
dirais même morale de l'exécutif est
engagé monsieur le premier ministre
alors que la presse savait que savait-on
au sommet de l'état
et depuis quand lorsque nous avons
constitué le gouvernement le président
de la république et moi même
croyez vous que nous aurions ayant le
moindre soupçon nous aurions proposé à
jérôme cahuzac de devenir ministre du
budget c'est à dire chargé du contrôle
fiscal
croyez vous que nous avions un doute
nous n'avions pas et nous avons cru à la
parole de cet homme et non seulement à
sa parole nous avons car comme tous les
membres du gouvernement
il a signé un engagement sur l'honneur
une charte de déontologie qui
l'engageait et qui engageait sa parole
et qu'il n'a pas respecté et aujourd'hui
comme vous je suis indignée tout
simplement parce qu'il s'est passé jean
marc ayrault n'est pas le seul à subir
les foudres de la droite deuxième
attaque en règle contre pierre moscovici
ancien ministre de tutelle de jérôme
cahuzac
oui ou non l'administration fiscale
at-elle été instrumentalisée pour
entraver la justice et pour étouffer
cette affaire
première question deuxième question
monsieur le premier ministre
oui ou non pierre moscovici ministre de
tutelle de jérôme cahuzac
at il voulu le blanchir en utilisant les
prérogatives liées à ses fonctions
si vous voulez à tout prix chercher une
mise en cause
je trouve que vous frappez vraiment à la
mauvaise porte
nous n'avons rien cherché à blanchir à
couvrir ou à excuser ou a innocenté au
contraire cette administration et moi
même avons été constamment au service de
la vérité toute la vérité et c'est cela
que nous avons fait j'en suis fier face
aux critiques le gouvernement de garde
sa ligne de défense
l'exécutif a fait confiance à jérôme
cahuzac et à laisser la justice
librement faire son travail
attaque tous azimuts donc dans
l'hémicycle la brèche dans laquelle
s'est engouffré l'opposition gérard
longuet c'est françois hollande ne
pouvait pas ne pas savoir vous
souscrivez il est question de bernard
acoyer christian jacob sens parfaitement
pertinente savait-on et pourquoi
l'architecte du gouvernement quel
président de la république
on savait moins que les médias c'est une
première question je n'ai pas la réponse
et je me garderai bien de trancher
mais cette question est parfaitement
légitime ensuite voilà quelqu'un qui est
attaqué et qui se sait attaquer il est à
l'intérieur de bercy il est donc là où
se contrôler les finances des
particuliers il n'est pas anormal que
christian jacob pose cette question le
la logique c'est d'aller dans le détail
des réponses et d'établir la bonne foi
des uns et les autres vous estimez que
la par exemple quand jean marc ayrault a
pris la parole n'était pas de bonne foi
moi je présume toujours la bonne foi je
présume l innocence de cahuzac
j'ai été comme beaucoup des trompes et
j'ai pas été trahi parce que je ne lui
avait pas donné ma confiance je ne serai
pas trahi non plus par jean marc ayrault
puisque je n'ai pas donné ma confiance
mais je crois qu'une question lui a été
posée est selon nous du calendrier on en
parle en décembre mais en réalité bien
avant des informations des rumeurs ont
circulé jeu participé à trois
gouvernements et en plus difficile et
nous avions entendu parler de ça vous
personnellement pas du tout mais les
journalistes qui en parle lorsque vous
relisez c'est vrai que nour lisant les
articles à la lumière de ce que nous
savons aujourd'hui c'est évidemment un
danger permanent que de faire l'histoire
quant on connaît là
la fin du parcours mais ceux qui sont
directement exposés c'est à dire
l'architecte de gouvernement ont petit
au fond qui nous explique qu'elle est
cette méthode
sa méthode de la confiance moi elle ne
me choque pas je le trouve au contraire
très belle est elle à la hauteur des
temps d'aujourd'hui
marc est donc c'est une bombe politique
on ne connaît pas encore les
déflagrations jusqu'où ça peut aller
selon vous quels sont les effets que
vous dites-vous sondages arriver avec un
chiffre 1 vont déjà confiance donc c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui françois hollande
est moins populaire que ne l'a jamais
été
nicolas sarkozy durant tout son
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy était bête
était tombé jusqu'à 30% confiance à ses
c'est peu et d'autant plus que rappelons
ce chiffre est issu d'une enquête qui a
été réalisée à cheval c'est de se dire
sur l' annonce pour l'aveu de jérôme
cahuzac que la sphère cahuzac on est
bien d'accord
donc ça serait d'ailleurs ça serait tout
à fait erroné de réécrire justement
l'histoire de l'impopularité actuelle ou
gouvernement et du président de la
république aux lumières cette affaire en
fait non c'est avant tout l'impuissance
du présent la république et du
gouvernement face à la crise à puissance
qui a été quasiment mise en scène par
françois hollande lors de son
intervention télévisée du 28 mars
lorsqu'il dit à la fois la crise est
plus dur que je croyais et en même temps
voici ma réponse
le show de simplification c'est cela
avant tout que sanctionne le sondage
c'est cela hélas ce sondage encore une
fois est intéressant en ce 6 milliard
seulement par son niveau global mais
également par le fait que avant même la
fare kérizac ap les sympathisants de
gauche comment ces aspects tels donné l'
affaire d'après ce que j'ai vu dans les
chiffres que je regardais comme la
seconde moitié du salaire et des
réponses
les interviews il apparaît qu'il ya un
effet d'accélération à la baisse liées à
la sphère cahuzac
donc on verra bientôt des sondages
encore pire que celui ci soit marie
gérard longuet comment le président peut
se sortir de cette spirale ou peut-être
commencer par le sondeur
jérôme sainte marie le sondeur n'est pas
là pour donner des solutions des
conseils en communication donc et du
conseil en actions surtout il s'agit
plus de communication il ya une habileté
qui a été fait c'est de lancer le débat
sur la moralisation alors qu'en fait
c'est quand même la question de
non il n'y aura pas de remaniement ça
vous semble la bonne sache pas vraiment
pour lui c'est le problème des français
n'est pas du tout à ces aspects de
mécanique politique si son cours s'ils
sont très loin des citoyens sont très
concentrés ou une mi-temps alors sortir
en allant au fond les coûts s'élèvent en
un jugement très politique vous savez
sur les choses sont très concentrés sur
la crise sur leur pouvoir d'achat sur le
risque de chômage ce qui voudrait
actuellement c'est un discours à la
limite n'importe quelles mains discours
clair une politique que l'on puisse
débattre
l'art de la synthèse de françois
hollande se retourne actuellement contre
lui y compris dans l'opinion à longueuil
vous attendez jean françois copé a dit
la première chose est la réponse de
jean-françois copé ça a été un
remaniement
si on entend ici les français c'est pas
le problème en fait le remaniement
j'étais avec des gens vont sur un coupé
je pense simplement que il faut que
françois hollande change de politique sa
politique n'a aucune probabilité de
succès aucune probabilité de succès
parce que le problème français c'est que
nos coûts de production sont trop élevés
que nos dépenses publiques sont trop
élevés et je reviens sur le remaniement
le changement de politique implique un
changement de gouvernement
ce n'est pas on remanie quand on a un
problème technique partiel avec des
braves gens qui ne sont à la hauteur à
nîmes en vous mais c'est pas le sujet
c'est une autre politique est donc une
autre et qu'il voulait de notre équipe
pour exprimer cette politique s'il
s'agit de remplacer un pas très bon
parent un peu meilleur sanaa simplement
aucune importance s'il s'agit de dire on
a compris pendant dix mois j'ai essayé
de faire la politique de mon programme
honnêtement ça ne marche pas parce que
ça ne peut pas marcher pas raison de
l'environnement international par
exemple pas tout à fait vrai mais enfin
à raison la ce a du sens de changer les
équipes parce qu'on change la politique
mais si on change pas la politique mieux
vaut usé les hommes alors le chef de
l'état ne m'en parlez ne pouvait pas
s'en tenir aux quelques lignes d'un
communiqué qui a été publié la veille
françois hollande a donc pris la parole
pour annoncer trois mesures écoutez
c'est un choc ce qui vient de se
produire parce que c'est un grave
manquement à la morale républicaine je
suis donc amenés à prendre trois
décisions d'abord renforcer
l'indépendance de la justice
c'est le sens de la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
ensuite lutter de manière impitoyable
contre les conflits entre les intérêts
publics et les intérêts privés et
assurer la publication et le contrôle
sur les patrimoines des ministres et de
tous les parlementaires
enfin les élus condamnés pénalement pour
fraude fiscale ou pour corruption seront
interdits de tout mandat public
jérôme sainte-marie s'en prendre à la
moralisation de la vie publique
c'est plutôt un bon point là pour
françois hollande parce que ça permet
quand même de sortir de cette affaire
qui a eu avec ben c'est une habileté
évidemment ce que lorsque les on met en
cause dans cette affaire là c'est pas du
tout des généralités sur la vie
politique c'est la composition du
gouvernement là le contrôle de ses
membres à tous points de vue
et puis également le fait qu'il ya
encore dix jours les français ont
longtemps à la télévision ont vu défiler
les ministres du gouvernement pour dire
que à quel point les usa qui était le
meilleur d'entre eux c'est ça le
problème
c'est là où ce n'est pas contrôlé alors
là on lance effectivement cet essai ce
sujet là on en parle la preuve ça
fonctionne un petit peu de la
magistrature on en parlait déjà sept
succès de la fois si vous voulez c'est à
la fois habile et dangereux habile parce
qu'effectivement on part sur des grands
sujets de société alors que c'est bien
là la conduite de la politique
gouvernementale qui est en cause et
c'est dangereux parce que ça donne
encore une fois la pression au français
qu'il le croit d'ailleurs que il ya un
immense problème de moralisation de la
vie politique que l'indépendance des
juges et confirmé par cette affaire le
président la république se fait l'écho
d'une donnée respect de préjugés qui
répondu à une population qui va pas
profiter au parti de gouvernement que la
pauvreté la démocratie en réalité il
faut savoir que la vie politique n'a
jamais était aussi à moraliser et jamais
je rappelle que juste quelques unes en
parle et pour sa part le sondage que
l'ia une affaire des sondages de
l'elysée uniquement que pour la première
fois troisième république la cour des
comptes et à l'elysée oui évidemment ça
donne l'impression inverse à l'opinion
s'émeut d'urgence
mais sa démonstration est en fait la
cour des comptes et à l'elysée parce que
le président nicolas sarkozy l'avait
voulu il avait demandé que les comptes
de l'elysée soit audité pour la cour des
comptes et la cour des comptes a audité
est signalé quelque chose qui lui
paraissait de atypique
les mesures proposées par conséquent ils
vont dans le bon sens pour vous elles
sont simplement elles sont anxiogènes
alors que la situation sur française au
fond des aînés pas si mauvaise
article est ce que la justice est
indépendante de la réponse est oui c'est
vous voterez vous la réforme du conseil
supérieur magistrature sur moi je
souhaite un conseil supérieur de la
magistrature où les magistrats ne va pas
majoritaires pourquoi parce que la
justice à partir tous les français et
les rendue au nom du peuple français les
par une nounou rendue au nom du corps
des magistrats
beaucoup de respect pour les magistrats
y consacrent leur vie à la justice ils
ne sont pas propriétaires de cette
autorité qu'est la justice article
article 2 les ministres les élus tous
les élus passent leur temps à faire des
déclarations
moi je suis un homme politique
relativement anciens jets je suis
contrôlé fiscalement tous les ans depuis
vingt ans tous les ans depuis 20 ans il
s'agit de rendre qu'eric votre
patrimoine est d'accord pour rendre
public votre déclaration de revenus et
de patrimoine vous même si vous voulez
ça me pose un problème de principe c'est
que quand j'ai choisi la vie politique
la règle n'était pas fixée bon à mon âge
je m'en fiche complètement
je peux rendre mon patron trois ans mais
si j'avais la réponse est oui ou oui
c'est oui mais parce que je pense que si
on veut des hommes politiques de qualité
il faut accepter et surtout si on
interdit le cumul il faut accepter qu'il
soit des élus et qu'ils aient une
activité professionnelle le cas échéant
si vous ne leur permettez pas vous aurez
des employés de parti politique comme
député et comme sénateur or quand vous
êtes quand vous travaillez pour vous il
vous arrive parfois de réussir n'est pas
obligé d'être condamné à l'échec pas aux
gens non aux élus de renoncer alors
alors bien on leur demande de les rendre
plus que vous
différents ou et pour en faire un thème
de campagne électorale
si vous le thème de campagne électorale
les deux suivants il se trouve que les
hasards de la vie politique j'en ai
souffert m'ont renvoyé dans le secteur
privé pendant dix ans j'étais élu local
mais je n'étais pas parlementaire j'ai
travaillé dans le secteur privé j'ai
gagné très honorablement ma vie je paye
les sf très honorablement tous les
électeurs ne sont pas forcément aptes ou
ont envie de comprendre comment il va
falloir que justifie chacun de mes actes
commerciaux
la conséquence pâte et je vais vous la
dire c'est que les entrepreneurs privés
n'embaucheront jamais d'hommes
politiques parce qu'ils auront le
sentiment qu'en embauchant un homme
politique
ils seront obligés de détaler sur la
place publique ce qu'est la vie des
entreprises on ne demande pas à un chef
de un patron du cac 40 on le demande ces
salaires parce que c'est en assemblée
générale
mais l'élu la république vous êtes
d'accord ça n'a rien à voir avec un
patron du cac 40 et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous mais si l'élu de la
république n'est pas est-ce qu'il est à
temps plein ou pas toute sa vie la
réponse est non il ne peut pas être à
temps plein parce qu'il ya les échecs et
les succès mais un succès prépare en
général un échec et réciproquement
et deuxièmement parce que l'idée
d'interdire le cumul qui n'est pas
forcément une mauvaise idée
nous avons eu nous sommes aujourd'hui à
mon avis un statu quo satisfaisant
permet d'étaler les risques mais vous
avez des hommes politiques qui
continuent de des chefs d'entreprises
parce qu'ils ont fait ce choix et vatan
les empêcher d hommes politiques sous
prétexte qu'ils réussissent dans
l'entreprise comme cadre salarié la
formation de gérard longuet va donc pas
forcément dans le sens de françois
hollande alors que vous disiez que
c'était une bonne proposition je serai
ravi de polémiquer sur ce plateau mais
il se trouve que là c'est d'accord et ce
qui va être dit le meilleur horaire à ce
charme particulier qu à la fois on
appartient à l'entreprise privée ce qui
est mon club depuis presque 25 ans et en
même temps on fréquente assidûment le
monde politique
évidemment les hommes politiques du
conflit entre les hommes et femmes
politiques sont astreints à une
discipline sans aucune mesure avec ce
qui existe dans le privé par ailleurs
effectivement la public on raisonne
toujours comme si les chefs qui font de
la politique protégeant ceux qui
réussissent à être élu eh bien allez
lettre toute leur vie c'est pas le cas
c'est pas le cas effectivement il ya là
ont touché quelque chose qui avec ses
déclarations
déclaré ponctuellement son patrimoine
c'est la bise parce que la déclaration
parce que parce que les gens se font une
fausse idée sur les moeurs politiques
sont fausses idées des revenus des
politiques
et justement peut-être de dégonflé ayant
en plus d'étrangers pour soyons très
honnête importance pour un électeur de
savoir que vous avez investi dans une
entreprise transparente non parce que ça
devient un sujet de polémique le fond du
problème est celui là parce que cibler
voûté tricoter assez rapidement la
totalité du vêtements que vous portez
parce que je vous donne un exemple très
simple vous réussissez à la tête d'une
entreprise on est à bout et demi c'est
normal parce qu'avec votre portefeuille
de contacts personnels vous ne pouviez
que réussir
donc il faut que monsieur untel qui vous
achetez un marché monsieur untel qui
vous achetez un camion monsieur untel
que vous avez vendu un immeuble il les
fait honnêtement donc nokia intel va
être impliqués et de proche en proche
c'est la totalité de vos relations
professionnelles qui vont être exposés
sur la vie publique
la conséquence pratique c'est que vous
ne pourrez plus travailler aux états
unis vous avez des milliardaires qui
font de la politique mais en général ils
le font après avoir été milliardaire ils
arrêtent et ils font la politique en
france c'est un petit peu différent et
ça rend les choses compliquées on voit
bien qu elle mange ans le 5 mars était
habile de la part de françois hollande
qu'on ne parle plus du cas qu'à usage à
cet instant à cet instant bleus n'ont
pas grand chose mais je pense que nous
avons traité le premier point mais je
suis persuadé vous allez me poser la
question sur le cac à usak maintenant
venir justement jérôme cahuzac
aujourd'hui donc un homme très sale
exclu du parti socialiste harlem désir
l'a confirmé les députés socialistes
l'ont clamé haut et fort jérôme cahuzac
ne peut redevenir députés comme il y
aurait pourtant droit ce qui ne passe
pas par dessus tout peut-être c'est
cette déclaration c'est en décembre dans
l'hémicycle je n'ai pas monsieur députés
je n'ai jamais eu de compte à l'étranger
ni maintenant ni avant je démens donc
ces accusations et j'ai saisi la justice
d'une plainte en diffamation car ça
n'est que devant la justice hélas que
les accusateurs doivent prouver la
réalité des allégations qu'il avance
jérôme sainte marie c'est peut-être ça
l'image la plus redoutable un mensonge
devant la représentation nationale
oui c'est plus simple pour lui c'est
plus redoutable le plus redoutable pour
moi encore une fois c'est ce qui se
passe il ya dix jours à dire quand elle
démissionne quand le doute existe y
compris le citoyen lambda y compris chez
moi d'ailleurs qui ne connais rien à
cette affaire de voir défiler tout le
ban et l'arrière-ban de du part
socialiste pour dire à quel point ce
type est formidable et maintenant on
nous explique que c était au banc de la
nation quasiment confirmée ou pas mais
c'est la première fois dans la vie
politique dans l'histoire politique
qu'un ministre avoue comme ça
publiquement une faute
est-ce qu'on peut au moins lui
reconnaître ça gérard longuet
normalement je connais bien l'histoire
politique jeu en effet je ne vois pas
tout à fait de présence y est il y en a
eu
sous françois mitterrand gilibert je
pense qui a été en effet condamné mais
qui avait reconnu cette faute
c'est le secrétaire d'état dégraisser le
seul je ne suis même pas certain de cet
exemple là je pense que c'est que le
premier mais quand même ça son actif
d'une certaine façon sorte un aveu
non parce que si vous voulez c'est
l'expression d'un sang-froid terrifiant
sent from mensonge 10600 froid au moment
du mensonge et j'ai presque envie de
dire sang froid au moment ce faire on
aurait aimé qui suit pas qu'éclate en
sanglots qu'ils soient humains humain
simplement qu'ils y attendait ses affres
c'est une truc épouvantable je suis un
pauvre type mais et on a l'impression
que c'est fait par internet ses prix il
se voit là c'est tout ce sang froid je
sens la pression qu'il dégage est celle
d'un immense mépris déjà ça se dégageait
un tout petit peu avant l aveu peu de
contentement de soi on peut le dire
voilà et donc là c'est une forme de
mépris supérieur en quelque sorte et
puis en plus les gens de son pays encore
une fois vous savez tout est décodé
immédiatement les gens comprennent bien
que il a peut-être il est peut-être
obligé pour se protéger lui même d'un
point de vue
judiciaire de d'avouer donc mais c'est
la fable de la fable qui tentait d'être
racontée chevauchent rien contre ce
monsieur que je ne connais pas mais les
gens ne les gens ne marche pas et ça
remplace arabe donne l'impression de
caste qui encore une fois pénalise
l'ensemble de la classe politique si on
ne peut parler classe politique est en
tout cas qui pénalise très durement
bien sûr sur ses fondamentaux même la
gauche au pouvoir merci jérôme
sainte-marie d'avoir participé en tout
cas sur ce point à notre émission j'ai
rendez vous restez avec nous bien
entendu on continue le film de la
semaine et mardi les sénateurs crie
victoire
la décentralisation est elle devenue un
dossier empoisonné pour le gouvernement
le pré ministre a décidé de revoir sa
copie et au vu des critiques de la
gauche et de la droite et bien trois
textes finalement seront séparés
présenter un petit peu plus tard au
parlement jean-marc euros et venues sont
expliqués devant le groupe socialiste au
sénat
les explications de paul bouffard
certains sont en colère d'autres sont
sceptiques
les parlementaires socialistes attendent
les explications de jean marc ayrault
sur l'acte iii de la décentralisation
un texte qui fait débat les sénateurs ps
espère un projet de loi plus clair plus
décentralisateur des régions aux fortes
pour l'emploi et l'économie des
métropoles du futur et une france des
départements et des communes qui
oeuvrent pour la solidarité au concret
au quotidien quand le premier ministre
arrive il se sait attendu les
applaudissements masque à peine la
grogne sénatoriales pendant plus d'une
heure le premier ministre présente sa
copie révisée à la sortie compte tenu de
la complexité du texte il annonce un
saucissonnage du projet de loi lebranchu
en trois étapes une sur les grandes
métropoles une seconde sur les régions
une dernière sur les solidarités
territoriales et notamment l'avenir des
départements c'est le grand chantier de
la décentralisation
alors nous voulons réussir ce chantier
là nous inscrivons notre action dans la
grande tradition des lois mitterand
moroy de fer et le sénat qui est le
premier destinataire de ces textes va
évidemment l'examiner en premier chez
les sénateurs ps les choses sont plus
claires on a des textes précis avec des
objectifs précis qu'on pourra d'ailleurs
amende et améliorer mais le débat il va
s'enraciner dans le concret alors qu on
était parti sur des choses qui était
moins facile à comprendre plus abstraite
et plus lourde
pas de report donc le texte sera
présenté au conseil des ministres le 10
avril prochain
gérard longuet est ce que c'est une
victoire des sénateurs
c'est presque la fin d'une réforme phare
du quinquennat
audika voulu par françois hollande celle
de l'acte iii de la décentralisation
on attend on peut attendre si on est de
bonne foi on peut attendre le
rendez-vous du 10 avril et puisque des
textes devraient présenter ou non ses
limites je tiens à vous dire que ma
connaissance ils ne sont pas connus du
grand public et connu des élus donc
certes les socialistes ont dû être
associés mais nous ne l'étions pas
visiblement si le texte est séparé en
trois c'est qu'il ya eu aussi chez les
élus socialistes une certaine pression
oui moi on aimerait connaître le fil
directeur le le fil directeur
aujourd'hui c'est une manipulation
électorale pour les municipales pour les
cantonales
donc pour les sénatoriales suis endormi
en les sénatoriales et conservatisme
total du millefeuille administratif
territorial français plus avec les
métropoles en plus ce qu'ils étaient en
filigrane dans nos travaux précédents
est ce que ça veut dire aussi d'une
certaine façon qui est heures possible
de toucher à cette décentralisation
française à ce millefeuille comme vous
l'appelez moi j'avais j'avais mais la
réforme territoriale précédentes parce
que elles aboutissent en fait à deux
pôles le communales intercommunales d'un
côté et je vois d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement n'a rien modifié et tant
mieux
l'intercommunalité associant des
communes autonome
ça marche et de l'autre côté nous avions
lancé le conseiller territorial c'est à
dire en réalité ce qui va se passer
dimanche je l'espère en alsace la fusion
la coopération institutionnelle
permanente on va l'appeler comme ça
des départements et des régions et ça
c'est indispensable parce que on aurait
avec deux pôles de suivi largement par
exemple propose de supprimer par deux le
nombre de régions faisaient pour c'est
un cadre des accords avec jean-pierre
parce que je considère que le tgv ça
vous faire sourire mais le tgv à changer
la france il est plus facile d'aller à
paris que d'aller dans une métropole
régionale
lorsque vous êtes en à bar-le-duc par
exemple le tgv vous conduit en une heure
à paris et il faut 1h15 de voiture pour
aller à metz donc aujourd'hui le nombre
de régions tactile et aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on ne peut garder ce nombre à
compte qu'à condition d'associer les
départements et 2 les deux fait avoir
une coopération permanente entre
départements et régions
sinon parce que ce que dit jean pierre
ils projettent les lander allemands je
les connais bien les longues de râles
montrent également encore une fois le
modèle allemand mais c'est un modèle qui
est historiquement fédéral avec
constitutionnellement des pouvoirs
locaux qui sont considérables par
rapport à nos pouvoirs
or pourquoi diable irions-nous à deux
heures de voiture de notre chef-lieu de
département dans une grande région
si il n'y a aucun pouvoir qui dit grande
région dit grande décentralisation sais
pas ce que veulent les français
les français veulent une solidarité
nationale et d une vie locale mais ils
ne veulent pas une véritable système
fédéral à voir donc sur ces lois sur la
décentralisation à venir à mauvaise
semaine décidément pour les promesses du
candidat hollande en ce mardi
il ya de la confusion peut le dire sur
la fameuse taxe à 75% sur les très hauts
revenus comme l'a annoncé françois
hollande elle sera prélevée à
l'intérieur même des entreprises mais
quelle taille pour les entreprises c'est
là la question
on n'est pas tout à fait sûr encore
d'avoir la réponse betty la guerre
nouveau rebondissement pour la taxe à
75% malgré sa censure par le conseil
constitutionnel fin 2012
le chef de l'état annonce la nouvelle
version de sa promesse de campagne
lors de son intervention télévisée mais
avec quelques changements
lorsque la rémunération dépasse 1
million d'euros est bien l'entreprise
aura une contribution à payer toute sa
position convenue
un drap 75% en clair ce sera désormais
aux grandes entreprises de payer cette
taxe et non plus aux salariés comme cela
était prévu initialement
mais ce matin nouveau cafouillage dans
le parisien noël le graet président de
la fédération française de football
déclare que les clubs professionnels
considérés comme des pme seront épargnés
par cette mesure assurant même avoir
posé la question au premier ministre
propos aussitôt démentie par matignon
qui répète que le dispositif concernera
toutes les entreprises qui versent des
salaires au dessus d'un million d'euros
dans les couloirs de l'assemblée côté
socialiste on parle d fort justifiée je
crois qu'il faut que tout le monde fasse
des efforts et que ceux qui ont la
chance justement un de percevoir des
hautes rémunérations et bien fassent
leur part aussi du travail
la droite elle tire à boulet rouge pour
elle cette taxe n'a tout simplement
aucun sens on a maintenant une sorte d'
usine à gaz ou les footballeurs vont
peut-être être taxés alors que les
acteurs ne le sont pas on le voit le
gouvernement dans une panade total
si cette taxe semble plus simple que
celle sur les revenus elle soulève
encore où beaucoup d'interrogations et
méritent encore d'être clarifiée par le
gouvernement usine à gaz et jean
françois lamour êtes d'accord j'y voyais
est claire soit au moins léger la
gazelle produisent du gaz tandis là
c'est du bricolage intégral qui ne
produit rien du tout à cet instant rien
du tout à cet instant et c'est
exactement un contre-pied et un
contresens qu'un particulier qui est un
très hauts revenus paye sur ses revenus
a nato sas a un sens de solidarité comme
le disait madame guigou
mais si c'est l'entreprise qui payent
que se passera-t-il belle entreprise
investira - l'entreprise paiera moins
ses autres salariés l'entreprise aura
moins de réserves qu'elle ne baissera
pas forcément le salaire de sa force à
revendre pas forcément parce que les
salariés diront battant des lames de
foot on va ailleurs pour les clubs de
foot et pour les cadres supérieurs
bon puisque c'est dure deux ans on va
attendre deux ans vous nous mettez cet
argent aux frais et dans deux ans vous
nous ressortez sans un mot gérard
longuet si vous étiez chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui vous resteriez aux france
je partagerai mes risques
d'ailleurs toutes les entreprises du
cac40 française
l entreprise je crois que la plupart
d'entre elles août aujourd'hui en
moyenne un chiffre d'affaires qui est à
l'étranger de l'ordre de 50 à 60 %
peu d'entre elles ont déplacé leur siège
une ou deux pas juridiquement mais de
fait pour l'instant on regarde les
sièges tant qu'on garde les sièges ça va
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les entreprises qui
veulent réussir et on ne peut pas leur
en vouloir
vont là où ça marche et la croissance
est forte en asie et les raisonnables en
amérique et les faibles en france est
manifestement elle va être faible c'est
d'ailleurs pas liée directement pour
être honnête à la simple aux simples
mesures socialistes
mais ces mesures socialistes dont un
autre effet elle décourage les jeunes
entrepreneurs
quand mitterrand a fait l'ijf en 80 de
ces livres qui sont partis mais il avait
déjà gagné leur argent et développer
leur entreprise aujourd'hui sont les
jeunes qui veulent s'enrichir et les
jeunes qui veulent s'enrichir sont
beaucoup plus intéressantes les vieux
parce qu'ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux
et ce sont eux qui peuvent créer la
richesse et ces jeunes là qui ont 25 ou
40 ans en effet aujourd'hui vont créer à
l'extérieur de la france et ça c'est une
perte sèche comparable la révocation de
l'édit de nantes
donc en passer au mercredi à l'assemblée
nationale ou par l'emploi
ah les députés attaque l'examen du
projet de loi sur la sécurisation y
emploie un accord signé entre
partenaires sociaux et que le
gouvernement veut transposer quasiment
tel quel dans la loi tous les députés
est d'abord ne l'entendent pas de cette
oreille c'est le cas des communistes et
des socialistes qui ont déposé de
nombreux amendements c'est ce que nous
explique elisa bartholomé début des
discussions dans l'hémicycle face à des
députés de gauche peu convaincu par le
texte le ministre michel sapin déploient
les grands arguments dans la période
très difficile que nous vivons où
certains aiment à parler de sang de
sueur et de larmes
je suis venu vous proposer du sens
les lueurs d'espoir et des armes des
armes contre le chômage
je veux le dire avec des mots simples
mesdames et messieurs les députés vous
avez dans les mains un de ses textes qui
laissent leur empreinte dans une
mandature un texte jugé historique par
le gouvernement mais qui à gauche de la
gauche est fortement critiquée en
premier lieu par le front de gauche
le groupe gdr a déposé plus de 400
amendements objectif faire traîner les
débats en longueur en discutant chaque
article quand un texte dans le mauvais
sens car il ne correspond pas aux
valeurs de la gauche
quand il est à l'opposé de ce qu'un
candidat de gauche a pu porter pendant
ces élections présidentielles on s'y
opposent avec détermination avec
compatibilité
c'est ce qu'on va faire toute la semaine
mais l'opposition le gouvernement la
trouve aussi au sein du groupe ps
l'ailé gauche du parti n'est pas prête à
voter le texte tel quel ni à se laisser
déposséder du pouvoir de légiférer
on tient compte de l'accord qui a été
signé par les partenaires sociaux
mais on est aussi dépositaire de la
magic chiffrage universelle qui nous a
confié le soin de faire la loi
faire la loi c'est pas s'il ya un accord
entre partenaires sociaux un accord que
le gouvernement a promis de respecter
les débats sont prévus pour durer
jusqu'à samedi prochain
alors gérard longuet s'arrête une
question parce que philosophique un
accord signé entre les partenaires
sociaux doit-il être transposée tel quel
dans la loi le tellement qu'elle le
telle qu'elle est et pour un
parlementaire à peu près insupportable
sur des raisons juridiques et donc
philosophique
mais la volonté nous l'avions fait nous
parlementaires de la majorité nicolas
sarkozy on avait voté le principe du
préalable de la négociation est dès lors
que la négociation avait lieu et
aboutissaient nous interdisions de
légiférer donc la situation est un peu
différente on laissait les partenaires
discuter librement
mais s'il n'aboutissait pas on prenait
la main là il emboutit saisi là les
parcs de masse sociologue city il aurait
donc fallu laisser ce n'était pas tout à
fait possible parce que certaines
dispositions que les parlementaires
aient les négociateurs sociaux ont
introduit sont de nature législative et
ça il fallait le leur dire avant et
docks a accompagné la négociation moi je
considère que cette négociation qui dans
l'esprit de la politique contractuelle
qui avait lancé nicolas sarkozy depuis
2008 et qui en est une forme de
prolongement entre patronat et syndicats
mérite d'être respecté donc vous
voteriez la loi vous votre je connais
pas suffisamment le texte mais je
voterai la loi au plus près de l'accord
parce que je considère que dans notre
pays souffre d'un manque de respect
mutuel et de politiques contractuelles
positive pour une fois que les syndicats
et le patronat s'entend pour quelque
chose qui ressenti comme pertinent ne
compliquons pas l'avis de du monde
économique et social est membre la
commission affaires sociales voire vous
y pencher sérieusement sur cette voie un
plus de flexibilité tel qu'il est
introduit la bienvenue l'inde est l'un
des problèmes français je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure c'est le coût du travail
mais dans le coût du travail
il n'y a pas simplement le coût global
les salaires qui sont moyens moyens
moyens et les charges qui sont fraude
aux autres il ya aussi la l'emploi c'est
vers la rigidité de l'emploi et
l'absence de donnant donnant je suis
plus flexible comme employeur mais vous
n'êtes plus soutenue
comme schumi il ya notamment du côté des
employés pour venir un petit peu leur
côté la taxation des contrats course ça
vous semble
c'est une punition stupide parce que ce
n'est pas moi je considère que c'est une
bonne action stupide parce que les
contrats courent c'est une forme d'accès
à l'emploi
et c'est pas du tout une manipulation
c'est une forme d'accès à l'emploi
maintenant si c'est le prix à payer pour
que syndicats et patronats s'entendent
il faut accepter de faire des
concessions moi je suis libéral c'est à
dire si les gens s'entendent jeu pas de
légiférer leur place la mutuelle pour
tous
la mutuelle pour tous à la condition de
savoir qui paye si c'est les mutuelles
c'est à dire les non salariés ça pose un
petit problème de solidarité pour signer
cet accord mais c'était quand même on
voit bien avec quelques mesures on est
on est obligé de regarder dans le détail
mais sauf s'il y a un objet fait un
obstacle irréfragable enfin une
opposition absolue
faisons confiance à ceux qui se sont
entendus laissez vous pencher sur ce
texte
voilà je n'ai pas la science infuse
j'attends de le voir le thé allez on va
passer au jeudi sujet là que vous
connaissez fort bien le mariage pour
tous ou par ce mariage
voilà je dis c'est donc au sénat qu'à
fait son entrée cette semaine ce texte
âprement discutée à l'assemblée on s'en
souvient au mois de février
il arrive au sénat sans qu une majorité
en sa faveur soit certaine qui et pour
qui et contre qui va s'abstenir marie
brémaud tente de nous faire voir plus
clair dernier rebondissement dans le
décompte des voix le sénateur fera sa
ump qui avaient voté pour le texte sur
le mariage homosexuel en commission des
lois votera contre
en séance à l'ump ils sont donc quatre à
vouloir voter le texte du gouvernement
jacqueline farreyrol alain milon
fabienne keller et christian cointat de
s'abstiendront alain fouché et roger
karoutchi
du côté des centristes la sénatrice udi
chantal jouanno et partisane du projet
de loi
d'autres préfèrent s'abstenir ce serait
le cas de muguette dini valérie létard
ou vincent capo-canellas de part et
d'autre on fait ses comptes
car au sénat la majorité dispose de
seulement six voix d'avancé sur
l'opposition
il y a quelques jours christiane taubira
et dominique bertinotti sont venus
s'assurer du soutien des sénateurs
socialistes et en grande majorité ils
voteront pour
mais à gauche des incertitudes
subsistent concernant les élus
ultramarins réticents au mariage pour
tous
il ya quelques heures le sénateur
apparenté ps de martinique maurice
antiste a annoncé son intention de
s'abstenir
même si les pro mariage reste confiant
le vote s'annonce plus serré qu'à
l'assemblée nationale verdict final dans
une dizaine de jours
alors gérard longuet votre position sur
la question et sans mystère vous êtes
contre et vous avez même des fins de vue
vendredi matin la motion référendaire
sur ce texte
enfin j'ai défendu la motion
référendaire parce que je considère que
ça correspond à un vrai besoin de la
république présidentielle
issu du quinquennat ça c'est le premier
argument
il n'y a plus de respiration politique
lorsqu'il y avait ce décalage entre
cette temps pour le président cinq ans
pour l'assemblée il y avait le rendez
vous législatifs qui permettait en
quelque sorte une soupape de sûreté si
on était en désaccord avec le président
ce qui est arrivé en 86 ou en 93 ou ont
voté aux législatives contre les contre
le président et on faisait apparaître
une nouvelle majorité aujourd'hui
pendant cinq ans
d'ailleurs si ce que nous disent les
socialistes à c'était dans le programme
ya le serment des folies bergères où on
à madame belkacem est venu dire que le
président le candidat était pour le
mariage pour la pmr paul gpa daïssala
khaimah parce que c'est aux folies
bergères que madame najat belkacem a
porté la parole du candidat françois
hollande font ça plutôt cocasse mais
enfin bon ça c'est une plaisanterie de
d'étudiant attardé en revanche sur le
fond le le vrai problème c'est qu'il
fallait parler de la famille qu'on en
parle par un billet qui est tout à fait
respectable car c'est tous les
homosexuels sont enfants d'hétérosexuels
donc les familles hétérosexuelles ce qui
est mon cas
nous avons une responsabilité vis-à-vis
des homosexuels parce que ce sont nos
enfants et parfois d'ailleurs nos frères
plus rarement nos ascendants mais ça
peut arriver
donc ce n'est pas un accord contre un
homme
autre ce n'est pas un choc d'un d'une
culture contre une autre c'est
simplement des français qui sont
attachés à une famille constituée autour
de la transmission de la vie ils disent
nous sommes singulier et nous voulons
que cette singularité soient respectées
les l'altérité de la condition
nécessaire mais pas suffisante de la
procréation ce que je refuse à cette loi
c'est de nier l'altérité et de d'ouvrir
des possibilités d'adoption qui
déboucheront presque inéluctablement
parce que les enfants adoptés sont très
peu nombreux ils seront de moins en
moins dans l'avenir vers un risque de
marchandisation du corps humain
l'adoption du mariage pour tous
l'adoption de ce que l'on veut bien
l'admettre change non oui mais si vous
avez le mariage pour vous un ragot père
si vous avez l'adoption parce que là
c'est que tient qu'aux biens très
clairement dit qu'ils n'étaient pas liés
et là tout à fait juridiquement tort il
le sait parfaitement la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme a été très clair à
partir du moment où les gens même statut
mariés ils ont les mêmes droits
adoption sas est irréfragable c'est le
cas de le dire
en revanche nous avons proposé c'est le
doyen gélard qu'il a présenté un contrat
d'union civile pour régler un des
problèmes que le pacs ne règle pas qui
est le lien entre dans le cas d'un
couple homosexuel du partenaire
permanent
lorsque le parent biologique disparaît
le partenaire permanent n'a pas de droit
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
proposé l'union civile devant le sénat y
avait eu de nombreuses manifestations
gérard longuet une forme de
radicalisation et même une sénatrice
chantal jouanno qui a eu le droit à un
réveil très matinal par les manifestants
on a même les citer le nom de ses
enfants
est-ce que vous admettez cette
radicalisation
l'attak personnel n'ont sûrement pas ma
permanence a été souvent murés ou tagués
par des opposants j'en fais pas une
maladie en revanche la tacc personnel et
le nom des enfants la réponse est non et
je sur ce point solidaire de ma collègue
chantal jours et vous le sentez vous
cette radicalisation des manifestants à
l'intérieur si voulez vous avez des
centaines de milliers de manifestants
certains d'entre eux ont des positions
extrêmes je le reconnai volontier
c'est vrai dans tous les cortèges
l'immense majorité ce sont des gens
savaient le mariage aujourd'hui n'est
absolument pas une obligation
les gens non mariés ont à peu près les
mêmes droits à quelques détails près
c'est un acte de foi et ceux qui
s'engagent dans le mariage ont envie de
le défendre tel qu'ils l'aiment et
malheureusement ils ont l'impression que
le gouvernement n'aime pas ce mariage là
parce qu'il le refuse
cette singularité exceptionnelle de
transmettre la mer dans votre camp donc
des sénateurs ump qui vont s'abstenir
oui et je vous dis je ça ne me posera
aucun problème parce que justement je
trouve qu'on a ouvert un très bon débat
sur la famille qu'il y a des gens qui ne
partagent pas ma conviction et le l'ump
au sénat à l'assemblée aussi d'ailleurs
laisse la liberté de vote donnent la
parole à ceux qui sont hostiles et nous
essayons de les comprendre et nous
essayons de nous entendre c'est
d'ailleurs le sens du texte du doyen
gélard sur l'hymne national espère sur
ce texte
la tolérance ne nuit pas s'il est si les
gens peuvent s'entendre c'est quand même
mieux que s'il s'accompagne ton courage
aussi parce que évidemment vous avait
siégé pendant des jours et peut-être un
plaisir de siéger je me suis battu pour
siéger je suis très content de siéger et
au courage à vous merci d'avoir
participé à notre émission on va se
retrouver la semaine prochaine au même
lieu même heure évidemment